[Music]
[Music]
get off pink soap coming off Bowl
counter him keep going through the wall
downstairs what's down here another wall
Wow got over TFR our hero
Oh y'all re on the bottle it operations
over the race driver
[Music]
do ya
that's obscene alternative it's the
Tomoana Coxon this is what's wrong no
Matt yep Oh what - Oh daddy they're
going to get out do you able to steal
this round away from West Ham right off
in there oh god oh my god oh wow that's
important
[Music]
California August amount of it gonna be
in ice need enough
one more big sub like that
[Music]
[Music]
oh wow a lot of these whips are just
bait you know you got to be careful
[Music]
oh the by car Takata survived one Hitler
final oh I'm so hot looking okay here's
the punish from cannon nice old Knight
lot a watch again trombone solo inbound
three in a row low often there is that's
what I've been talking about big Hawk
takes very very dangerous wild July why
did bed oh man he's gonna be so
disappointed we gotta look at the play
out of sight that day oh gosh
Patton could not believe it he looked
around in disbelief
[Music]
you
[Music]